joining us now live he's in the white
house as we speak is the president of
the united states mr president
uh thank you sir for joining us
appreciate you being here
thank you sean let's start with
the big news today kamala harris your
your initial thoughts
well if you read the various political
pundits you would have said that maybe
that would have been the one a lot of
people think it's a dangerous choice i
think you know she's the most liberal
person
supposedly in the senate that's pretty
liberal
but she's supposed to be the most i'm
not sure that's what the country wants i
think if it is we've got problems but i
would be surprised if it is she
wants to raise taxes she wants to get
rid of your second amendment
no guns for protection no nothing she's
very strong in the second amendment
getting rid of it
and very bad to the military she wants
to cut the military she wants to
cut spending for the military and the
vets
and you know i don't quite get the
choice but
we'll have it out we have a great vice
president named mike pence and
he will take care of business just like
he did the last time against a different
candidate
well vice president pence by the way
will exclusively join us on this program
tomorrow
let's go through some of the specifics
she was one of the first democrats to
co-sponsor i call him bolshevik bernie
bernie sanders
who by the way he used to be an outlier
in the democratic party
um and and way outside the democratic
mainstream
she co-sponsored his not only a single
payer
medicare for all which would be anywhere
estimates from 32 to 54 trillion dollars
she wanted to eliminate private health
insurance
even for americans that like their plan
um that sounds extreme sir
well that's 180 million people and they
love their plan not like it and they
don't want to take it away
and if you go into socialized medicine
which is what she wants and supports
strongly
and it's what biden wants ultimately
it's not going to have a choice because
his party wants it the people that
really control the party he will never
control the party
they want it that means you're
destroying something that
180 million people love they have a plan
that they really like that's a
that's a very hard thing to do very hard
thing to do and by the way i have to say
larry
and leo and janine and your great
senator john kennedy who's fantastic and
karl rove who's been so great last
you know carl and i had our disputes
previously
we like each other a lot now he's been
great but carl was great tonight and i i
will say that was
some little precast i had on that was
very impressive thank you
that that's i guess that we call that
the opening act uh
mr president um they were good
i i've talked a lot about this and when
you were a candidate i asked you many
many times about the need for america to
become
energy independent and you went forward
with the keystone xl pipeline uh the
dakota pipeline you've opened
anwar and for the first time in 75 years
america is now energy independent and
we're now also it's been a longer period
of time the
largest producer of energy in the entire
world
uh she was a co-sponsor in the us senate
of this radical green new deal
uh joe biden has already pledged
trillions of
taxpayer dollars for for that plan
um and uh all i see is that would
eliminate
uh you know the lifeblood of the the
world's economy america's economy
in in the next 10 years according to the
original plan that she again was a
co-sponsor of
how do you see that in terms of the geo
political strategic
even defense uh of this country because
that to me is a
crucial program that uh is scary
you know to go back to energy
independent uh dependence is scary to me
well we are now energy independent for
the first time
i guess ever and we're very powerful on
energy and
and we when we had the pandemic hit us
from china which should have never
happened they should have never let that
happen
but there was obviously a lot of energy
around and
we saved it i saved it we called russia
president putin we called the king of
saudi arabia they
cut 10 million barrels of oil a day
and we saved the energy and now we're at
41 dollars
a barrel but more importantly for the
people driving cars we're around two
dollars and even less
a gallon and that's fantastic she's
against
petroleum she's against fracking so is
biden
and that means you can't win texas you
can't win pennsylvania you can't win
oklahoma or north dakota or many other
states
and it also means your electric bills
would go up
literally by 10 times
you wouldn't it wouldn't be even
sustainable and if they went with this
crazy grunt it's it's like child's play
if they went with the
so-called green new deal you're talking
about
uh a catastrophic for the country you'd
probably have to close
20 to 25 percent of your businesses even
to qualify
and they wouldn't function properly
because we don't have that kind of
energy
it's crazy this can't they can't power
our massive we have these massive
plants some of which and many of which
are being built under me the
car companies are moving back from japan
and from
other countries coming in from germany
they're coming back to america first
time in 42 years
and you can't even think about firing up
those plants with the kind of things
they're talking about
wind is nice it's nice it's but it's uh
it causes tremendous environmental
problems
from sight to home values going way down
if you see a windmill and you hear a
windmill
your home is worth half or less than
half it kills all the birds
the whole thing is crazy what they want
to do and they'll destroy the country
we've built the greatest and if you see
what's happened we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world
better than china by far we were lapping
them and then all of a sudden
when the plague came in we had to close
it down we saved millions of lives and
now we're opening it up
and we're setting records and you even
see the stock prices today where the
markets are
nasdaq is higher than it ever was and
the dow
is just about ready i mean it's right at
almost at the same level
who would have believed that in the
middle of a pandemic which
we're soon going to have vaccines and
therapeutics it's going to be
it's going to all be good next year
we're going to have one of the greatest
years we've ever had
if it isn't blown out the window by
tripling
and quadrupling taxes and regulations
let me specifically go into the issue
and it was a signature issue for you
in 2016 and that is uh building the wall
and and and you can update us on that
part
um and yeah it was a heavy lift
uh and you had to find a way to
reallocate funds from the defense
department another where but
uh and elsewhere uh but you have two
candidates now that support
amnesty kamala harris supports sanctuary
cities the sanctuary state of
california wants to eliminate ice
your reaction to the the very different
positions
that you have on this very key issue and
an issue that has defined your first
campaign and is a big issue
still today so the wall is well under
construction we have 281 miles
up 281 miles that's one of the reasons
that the border numbers are so good
because wherever it's built nobody comes
through you can't
get through it unless you're a climber
of mount everest that's about it you'd
have to be
of that talent uh so we have uh
281 miles the rest is being built by the
end of the year it'll be mostly finished
we may add another 50 miles
that was unplanned for in certain areas
that are
a little bit tough so we'll make that
determination
but the wall is built you don't hear
about that anymore sure remember that
was like the biggest topic as soon as i
won
the democrats stopped talking about it
and when they stop
their uh their co-partner stops that's
the media the corrupt the media the fake
news so you don't hear about it but the
wall is going up and having a
tremendous impact and it's exactly what
the border patrol wanted we designed it
together
and it's exactly what they wanted they
wanted steel concrete and rebar i said
how about one they said we need all
three
for strength and for other reasons
security so that
and if you look at ice these people are
incredible they're taking out
thousands of ms-13 gang members these
are the roughest there are anywhere in
the world
they're crazy they're crazy and we're
either bringing them back to their
country
or when where we're putting them in jail
in some cases we really have to put them
in jail we don't want to have to pay for
them for the next 50 years but we don't
want to
take a chance they're so violent they
kill people with knives because it's
more painful
and it goes slower that's what they say
it goes slower and it's more painful
we're taking them out by the thousands
and guatemala if you look at guatemala
honduras el salvador these are countries
that wouldn't take people back
tremendous problems came to our country
they wouldn't take them back
now they take them back you know we were
paying them for years
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
ridiculously
and i said you mean we're paying him the
money we don't take them back we bring
them to the country they wouldn't accept
they wouldn't let our planes land before
me
and when i got there i said well if they
won't do that then we're not going to
pay them anymore once they said that
we stopped paying them and then all of a
sudden they take
these people back gladly with they're
very very happily
mexico has 27 000 of their soldiers
on the southern border and people aren't
coming in now they don't go past the
mexican soldiers so
very very few people coming in illegally
and uh
then that's helped of course by the wall
so we've made tremendous
strides we let people come in legally we
want people to come in
through merit where they can help our
country where they can love our country
and that's what's happening and
the democrats stay away the i call them
the radical left because
if you look at the races you look at
some of the races that are taking place
all of these old mainline older mainline
democrats are being beaten by radical
left
i don't know i guess you could say
anarchists in a certain way but the
people that are winning these races for
the democrats
elliot engel he was a staple many many
years and
you know who i'm talking about a staple
from
a very nice part of the world that's
going bad on us new york
it's going bad i left there it was four
years ago it was
it was a wonderful place you could see
signs of badness but it was a wonderful
place and now it's
it's crime is up by many many times and
what's happening in new york is so
horrible for our country what they've
done what mayor de blasio has done to
that city in a short period of time
is is horrible but you look at elliot
engel gets beaten easily by
a radical left and the democrats that's
where they are
they don't want petroleum they don't
want second amendment
they don't want religion they don't want
anything it's a
it's disgraceful let me go to
you know i played at the beginning of
the program it was interesting to me
that you had tweeted out almost within
minutes
today uh the ad about kamala harris
and did you have an instinct that it was
gonna be kamala or perhaps the names
that had been mentioned the most did you
have ads prepared for all of them
no but we really have some very talented
people it was quick
and we have some talented people yeah i
thought it might be her
because if you remember she was going to
do very well
she was one of the people that was
projected to have a chance at winning
and all she did is people got to know
her she went down she finished at two
percent
probably less than that and she fled
remember how quickly she said horrible
things about biden the one thing i felt
he couldn't do i mean she
took what some body said about her some
horrible things about was said about
joe and she said she agreed with the
woman that said them that was a terrible
statement and i said you know
just that statement alone but she made
terrible statements she
essentially called him a racist and
other things that were very bad and you
know i said we probably can't pick her
but
let's do something on her because people
were saying it could happen and we had
others in mind also we had some
we had some other choices she was my
number one draft pick she was the one
that i thought
would be uh the best for us you're
number one mike
number one mike is a pro